[Musique]
vous écoutez france info ajoutant je
trouve ça formidable c'est magnifique
parce que quand on est en voiture et
qu'on fait un trajet de 10 minutes ou
d'une demi heure quand on sait que on a
raté ou la composition du gouvernement
où le résultat d'un match de football on
sait que ça va arriver ça c'est une idée
magnifique
alors vous le savez cette grande chaîne
radiophonique fête son dixième
anniversaire
rappelons qu'il a été créé par an
loafers et jérôme bene le 1er juin 1987
c'est roland faure j'ai allumé legs et
c'est un réseau radio france ça vous le
saviez reportage le rachel bosseur
[Musique]
dimanche 1er juin la radio qui rapproche
le monde souffle ses dix bougies
dix années d'information en continu
imaginé par roland faure à l'époque
président de radio france et par jérôme
bellay d'après le modèle d'une radio
locale américaine
le concept est alors unique 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24
france info donne les dernières
nouvelles du monde c'est l'époque de
l'information en temps réel ou presque
la formule marche bien en disant france
info a triplé son budget et quadruples
et le nombre de ses producteurs
parmi les plus connus yolaine de la
bigne michel cymes ou encore michel diss
et paul wermus autant de respirations
entre deux flashs info france à fos et
bien sûr l'événement mais aussi une
équipe de 53 journalistes constamment
sur le terrain
aujourd'hui l'actualité c'est la
passation de pouvoir entre alain juppé
desnel jospin sylvie johnson journaliste
politique à france info est dépêchée sur
place pour une retransmission directe
les celui comme en ce moment je vais
rappeler cette anecdote ce matin alain
juppé en 1993 lionel jospin avait été
battu à cintegabelle
ils voulaient tout simplement abandonner
la politique il avait demandé à
réintégrer son corps d'origine
c'est-à-dire le quai d'orsay il voulait
une ambassade il voulait prague et un
adulte et qui est à ce moment là
ministre des affaires étrangères avait
fait traîner le dossier bp tout le monde
parlait de faire de créer et de lancer
une radio d'information cdu lorsqu'elle
est né il favori dans les premiers mois
je t'aime dans les deux trois premières
années bien peu et lyon au départ
son slogan c'était pour gagner son temps
cerexhe l'époque était très différent 87
la vitesse est à la mode des années un
peu paillettes commande alors dix ans
ont passé on a besoin de beaucoup plus
d'explications de beaucoup mieux
comprendre l'actualité donc au delà des
titres de la première alerte que
constitue toujours france un coup il
faut toujours plus d'écho d expliquer
c'est pas la compil de l'info russie
ce qui toujours à france info on a
l'ambition de faire la photo de
l'actualité mais aussi la légende
pendant les premières années on a
beaucoup fait de photos d'actualité
c'était très intéressant mais on a senti
la nécessité je dirais que ce sont les
auditeurs qui nous l'ont réclamé tout
naturellement et nous notre démarche est
allé dans le même sens expliqué expliqué
explique manche partout et 2 jeux à 1
dans la troisième et dernière manche
pour ivan à roland garros georges
mougeot france info et retour à roland
garros en direct un français journal
france info sports
l'avenir de france info c'est des
petites soeurs pour prendre sa peau elle
permettrait de dire sur france info on
prend un premier service mais allez
allez donc écouter france info sports
prenons un seul exemple roland garros
que vous pouvez suivre que vous avez pu
suivre de la première à la dernière
balle ses vraies priorités à tout moment
aux journalistes qui sont à roland
garros mais on ne couvre pas tout roland
garros donc j'imagine très bien qu'un
jour on puisse dire après deux minutes
de roland garros sur france info france
info sport telles fréquences je ne la
connais pas encore aujourd'hui vous
propose de suivre en intégralité cette
fois roland garros puis messieurs le
tenant du titre le russe il aime bien
l'idée qu'on ne peut pas contrôler le
mollah divers musées ou rpm également l
affiche de cette journée ma rencontre
encore le suédois magnus norman le
slogan de france info dans cinq à dix
ans et sa petite fille qui nous
l'apprendra donc cette petite fille
quand on la retrouvera à la coupe de
france info je suis sûr qu'à nous
écoutent déjà mais quand elle sera
comptabilisée par exemple dans les
sondages c'est plat si important que ça
mais tout de même
dans 5 ou 10 ans et bien le dira voilà
ce que j'attends de l'information qu'il
y a dix ans peu de gens parier sur
l'avenir de la petite dernière de la
bande fm
et pourtant aujourd'hui france info
occupe le quatrième rang sur les ondes
nationales
les dix ans donc vous connaissez le
générique là alors qu'est-ce que je
l'entends du pendant la guerre du golfe
s'est extrait tout le temps tout en
toile
[Musique]